the world's biggest chess streamer may
be the next world chess championship
challenger meet hikaru nakamura the
american chess legend who has millions
of followers watching him play chess
daily once the youngest american grand
master in history nakamura has won five
u.s national titles he's also been
ranked as high as number two on the
official chess rating list he's been the
most dominant online player ever winning
dozens upon dozens of titles in the
pandemic nakamura's career as a chess
streamer ascended to new heights and at
this time he said that he was no longer
a chess professional but a chess
streamer instead that's why some were
surprised when it was announced that
nakamura would join the 2022 fide grand
prix as an invited player silencing
naysayers nakamura won the event with
brilliant play and he qualified for the
2022 candidates tournament more
confident than ever nakamura has showed
that he's ready for a good fight that's
why